hey guys Ryan right in the right corner
right now and on our left side we have
Jerry and Jerry we're gonna be checking
out the video today called Star Wars vs.
DC Marvel
I don't know if it's DC versus Marvel or
DC and Marvel but let's find out epic
fan made trailers Alex Luthor is the
[ __ ] he commented did it really he
commented on one of our videos dude yeah
it's like we said two very different
things and they were both very much
awesome Lex Luthor yeah
he's never seen one of these by the way
is the only way see Britney's it is
pointless to resist
it's uncool yes
there is a great disturbance
this station is now the ultimate power
in the universe the ability to destroy a
planet is insignificant next to the
power of the force
Sigma
let's kill an entire race
that's great
ah
ha how sick is that that's [ __ ]
awesome
not pretty I love I love how they took
the story of DCM horrible need to help
each other to go against the dark side
you know it's smart that they don't take
all the Star Wars characters because
they took this [ __ ] out of all the money
because there's a lot of good in the
Star Wars characters yeah they only took
the dark side of them and made that the
enemy you know I thought that was very
clever these trailers are brilliant like
the editing of them it's this wallet for
they must take a long time to find the
right clips and then to do all like
inserting Darth Vader here and inserting
yes are there like these must take
forever like well done there'll be
moments where the editing has flawless
where it's like I only I'm aware that
that's a cut because I've seen the
actual movie but he takes them not just
from the movies he takes it from the
trailers he takes it from the actual
movie he takes it from the shows video
games like he he takes it all and he
makes it [ __ ] work like it's
brilliant
good get your hopes up yeah he gets her
hopes up and then crushes you
immediately when you realize this is a
rig yeah a [ __ ] heart thanks for
breaking my heart
like teasing me okay I'm sure it's like
when Veronica was like hey we can have a
threesome and then she brought Megan Fox
to the door I was like holy [ __ ] I'm at
the buck Megan Fox and my girlfriend's
okay with this but that Veronica gave me
the middle finger and said never mind
this is a really weird story no it's
well it really late it relates to my
experience with seeing this and then
going oh it's not really gonna happen
yeah but whatever I could do that just
seems like such strange behavior I don't
know but it got me so horny for her it
has really improved our sex life yet
something about like every time I get
hurt I'm more drawn to her
you know it's really healthy relations
this is joe cassano Gerudo yokas gonna
leave you a lot of cookies that's not
true she's never gonna watch this videos
been realities that's not true like we
have a really loving relationship and we
have the best sex they need to know that
how great we are because it's true we
are why would else what we would have
together
well they all know that I'm taking care
of their family member if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects Jerry has a show out in
this channel too called reasons to Jerry
yeah Jerry just joke right now no Jerry
just jokes but especially cuz like if
you didn't watch the no other video
where we said that right before this one
it's not gonna make sense yeah but maybe
that's more incentive to go back and
scour all the videos all of them not
just the most recent yeah you gotta go
find the context
Jesse Carrillo he said shout out please
well Jesse even someone say it as he's
screaming it Jesse is no young kid it's
rocking a Superman shirt in this photo
this is good Jesse I'm gonna keep this
age-appropriate at all do you I'm gonna
be honest if you're watching this
channel you're not gonna have a good
personal life the way your mentality is
currently developing by listening to
someone like me it is inspiring you to
do really bad things just horrible
things you know like this is why there's
Christian groups that hate on people
like me to me I'm a symbolism of life
okay what life means but life is but you
know for some people they're not gonna
agree in your parents we're not gonna be
cool with knowing you're watching me
but look at the word masturbator no one
day you will
don't don't listen to a word this man
says just it's a healthy thing to do
you guys cover life on your own when you
get older you will love this word no
that's all I'm gonna tell you look it up
when you're like 13 or 11
don't y'all heard about it at school by
then good take care now Jessie Jessie
yes